[موسيقى]
لماذا هذا اللقب لان اتقن من اشد المعجبين
به هتلر والرموز النازيه على جسده وشوم
مستوحاه من الريخ الثالث والرسوم الفاشيه
ويقال انه ما يزال على التزام تام بهذه
الايدولوجيه
[موسيقى]
حدثونا عن رجل عظيم اسمه بشار الاسد قالوا
انه رجل طيب يحاول وحيدا مع جيشه البطل
محاربه الامبرياليه العالميه هذا الرجل
الطيب بحاجه للمساعده
[موسيقى]
شهاده الوفاه هذه وصلتني مع نعشه
خيل اليه ان مغامرته ستحسن من مستوى
معيشته كل شيء مرتبط بالمال فالشاب يريد
ان يحظى برغد العيش ولكن احلامه كانت
مجنونه
تمنيت لو عمل معامله البطل
وان يعترف به جنديا نظاميا يذو عن السلام
لا مرتزق
ابني لم يكن قاتلا ماجورا
[موسيقى]
في هذا الفيديو الذي تخالطه موسيقى بهيجه
نرى رجالا مرحيا يتحدثون الروسيه معهم
مطرقه ثقيله يضربون بها رجلا عربيا ملقا
على الارض ثم نرى كيف قطع هؤلاء الرجال
اطرافه وعلقوه من رجليه ثم جزوا راسه
واشعلوا النار في جسده
[موسيقى]
وهل يستطيع هذا الجيش التحرك دون اذن
حكومي
لا يمكنهم ذلك فالحكومه هي التي تتكفل
بتجهيزهم والرجال في كثير من الاحيان جنود
احتياط يؤمن لهم الماكل والملبس ويستخدمون
وسائل النقل وامداد تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
تنشرهم في الاماكن التي يتعين عليهم خوض
عمليات قتاليه فيها من الواضح ان فاجنر
تابعه للحكم
[موسيقى]
شاهدت كل مقاطع الفيديو التي صورتها دائره
المراسم الرئاسيه لم اكن املك الى فكره
ضبابيه عن ملامحكين فجاه رايته جالسا في
لقطه جانبيه انه هذا الرجل ذو الوجه
الاعجى في المميز
[موسيقى]
لسنا بالمتهورين الذين يستسهلون اعدام
الافارقه الفقراء فهؤلاء ليسوا خصومنا ما
اعنيه بقوله هو ان هدفناؤه هو العالم
الغربي
بايديته وقيمه لقد نشانا نشاه مختلفه
وننظر الى العالم نظره مختلفه
[موسيقى]